what are the three qualities that you're
looking for in a woman
sophisticated submissive and sexy hmm
that's the three right there three s's
by the way yeah you know i'm gonna do
the word please
dude there's a bar right here you heard
me real righteous and relevant
sophisticated what else submissive
submissive and sexy okay so we all know
what sophisticated means you want a
classy woman there you go freaking the
uh
lady in the streets freaking the sheets
and let's make sure that they know that
it's sophisticated doesn't mean that you
had to have a 36 on your a.c.t or that
you had to go to an ivy league school
like harvard or something sophisticated
just means this culture where we
celebrate
women being ditzy and dumb and and fast
and city girls and all this stuff man f
that culture you know what i mean like
nah i want someone who's classy like
like literally is there a woman who
comes to mind that is sophisticated you
say okay that's the type of person that
i just sophisticated i'm not saying for
all three
the sophisticated part yeah michelle
obama okay there it is again yeah claire
huxtable
you know all right so so sophisticated
yeah just classy because i might have
you in the hood with me one day in the
ninth ward of new orleans where i'm from
yeah but i might have you on harvard's
campus with me the next day i don't need
you thinking that you know popping your
booty twerking you know to the elevator
music and cutting up is is what's up you
know what i mean there's a time and a
place for that you heard me don't get it
twisted yeah there's a time of the place
you're gonna pop that thing girl just
not right but not in front of not in
front of my classmates
okay so sophisticated yes sophisticated
submissive submissive yeah that's
another terminology that gets thrown
around the red pale space what does that
mean to you yeah that means that i'm the
leader um i don't mind being the bread
winner you know that's not a that's not
a a hard thing for me that's not
something that i'll ever go back and
forth with a woman on it's like well you
need to be paying for this and that i
know god has blessed me and i've made
i've made moves in my life already that
are going to benefit
my future wife and my future kids and i
don't even know who they are yet you
know what i mean but i've already made
financial moves made sacrifices as a man
things that i could have bought that
would have just been a waste of money i
chose to make investments now that have
multiplied and quadrupled
you know what i mean i think the same
way by the way yeah bro so so you know
we met at a financial literacy exactly
we're going to touch on that exactly bro
that being said i need someone who's
submissive and
with my what my brothers are saying is
really cool because
i recognize that women look for status
right so
a lot of times women won't submit if
upon first glance it's not a man who is
like oh my gosh he's six foot six you
know super big muscles he you know he
talks real aggressive like okay i'll
submit to him you know but a lot of
times a woman won't submit to a man
who's like yo i'm a christian yo i'm
super respectful i don't even curse you
know what i'm saying like i'm i'm a man
of god i make sure that i show people
love that's how i move about this world
a lot of times women who take that as oh
that's not dominant i can't submit to
something like that you know what i mean
and that's this is the kind of the
pushback that you get from women i think
there was some women well first of all
um uh
like how my man said he uh always act
poor i always act poor you know what i
mean so when you act poor i drove around
a 1998 honda accord until last year you
know what i mean on purpose like didn't
have to be driving that at all i'm not
surprised the car lasted but i guess
those cars didn't last a long time yeah
it had 400 000 miles on it when i
finally got right so is it more acting
poor or just staying humble uh for me
it's it's staying humble but i realize
that by staying humble you are
constantly being assessed and compared
so women are looking at it like well
he's cute but he pulled up in a 1998
honda accord meanwhile that other guy on
instagram who tried to highlight me
who's cute he pulled up in an audi you
know what i mean so i think i'm gonna
give him that the advantage and i think
i'll be more willing to submit to
someone like him i don't want you to
submit because of my material
possessions i want you to submit because
of my mindset
you're filtering yeah
exactly i want you to submit because of
my my mindset and my philosophy i want
you to submit because of my belief in
god and not just my belief but like my
my adoration for my obedience to god so
that should make you realize you're
submitting to a lifestyle you're not
submitting to a few material possessions
that that make you say oh girl he pulled
up in this type of call whatever he want
i'm i'm i'm here i'm always you're
easily viable either
the third one would be sexy okay yeah
sophisticated submissive and sexy the
sexy part comes with being knowing how
to be soft you know um you don't have to
have any fake work done for me
personally you know you don't have to go
and get bigger breasts or a bigger butt
artificially i know i'm in miami right
now this is what dr miami huh that
that's this way it gets done that yo you
trying to get shout out to uh lenny
hockstein my boy he's uh that's my guy
okay
yeah so you know what like i'm not even
saying that when i say be sexy i'm just
saying yo like be
be someone who understands that as a
don't try to convince me that as a man i
shouldn't be worried about how you look
there's some women who'll try to like
don't try to convince me i like what you
said right there yeah don't try to
convince me that looks don't matter some
women will really try to convince you
that like hey
you shouldn't just be worried about how
i looked almost like that's shallow and
i feel like you're trying to negate my
manhood you're trying to like cut off my
testicles by trying to tell me
how how worried i should be so let me
ask you something you're a rapper you've
done collabs with uh
nicknames the game okay the game the
game is on my album that i just dropped
lupe fiasco is on my album i just
dropped big big critters on my album
with manny fresh manny's friends
exactly that's what i'm saying yeah of
course you're people so have you ever
done anything with lizzo
you've never done anything she's very
talented super talented okay now if you
can do something with this you would but
there's also something i wouldn't do
with it okay and what's that what i
would do is music
what i wouldn't do is
you know
you're not listening to keith sweat in
the bedroom with lizzie
and why is that d1 you're respectful
dude yeah i'm a respectful dude and i
respect lizzle you know and lizzle is
for somebody yes you know just not me
and you say that it would be fair to say
that she's not easy on the eyes to a guy
like you yeah to me personally i'm not
physically attracted to lizzle and i
shouldn't get
attacked by a bunch of women for saying
that because i can't see the headlines
musically i love you lizzo there you go
sexually
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire sauce cast click right
here
[Music]